with a new Marvel show or movie I always
feel like one of the hardest things to
do is to make it feel like it fits the
MCU but it also has your own stamp on it
so can you tell me one specific thing
you did to make sure it feels like the
MCU we know and love but then also
something you did on secret Invasion to
make it feel like your own uh I think
this um this is a very different show
from the MCU in that it it shows us a
new Nick Fury it delves into a human
story about a man with his feet on the
ground rather than a story about people
flying in the air
um and yet Nick Fury is an anchor in the
MCU and we know him so I think any focus
on Nick Fury makes it part of the MCU
and I was really drawn to the themes of
trust and suspicion and paranoia and
identity and for me coming from a spy
background and and
um you know CIA stuff and the work I've
done in the past I immediately wanted to
take this in the direction of film Noir
and things like we studied the third man
and we studied copilus the conversation
and in some instances we stole from them
and put it right in these episodes so I
think it's it's a balance of how do you
Shepherd what fans love about the MCU
and yet keep them
surprised No Stealing you inspire and
use it to make something else even
better well there's there are a couple
shots in episode five you'll be like oh
I know what that's from I can't wait to
look out for that so you made those two
references what about past MCU films or
shows was there any specific one that
maybe you looked to to you know work
into the style of your show more so than
anything else in the franchise I think
less about the style and more about the
story telling
um I I had to watch Captain Marvel
because that was the beginning of this
relationship between Talos and fury and
a lot of references to Winter Soldier
um but I also went back and watched a
lot of the the Marvel world because I
had to understand the relationships and
um where they came from and where they
started and so but not necessarily
visual reference because I think we
wanted this to be darker and more Noir
than
um a typical MCU great success in that
respect I was getting the feeling from
the opening sequence but the second the
title card and the music that plays
there kicked in I kind of was like
buckle up this is going to be something
different that I kind of like I hope it
delivers um I am curious about how you
all came to the decision for you to
direct all the episodes of this show
because when it comes to MCU series
we've seen some with one director for
all episodes but others where the duties
are split up so what was it about the
secret Invasion story that made you all
think that it is best to leave this all
in one person's hands as director well I
wasn't in on those conversations so uh
clearly I had said something that
resonated and a series of circumstances
led me here and I come from a filmmaking
background so I'm really grateful to
have sort of helped create this as a
film
um or one big story whether you want to
call it a film or absotic TV but the
decisions that were made to bring that's
that's something else above my pay grade
I also feel like what's the difference
anymore it's just storytelling peers
it's true storytelling in any format on
any medium I don't care it's just
storytelling this feels a little unfair
because it feels like I'm asking you to
pick a favorite child but going into
filming secret Invasion which Marvel
character were you most excited to get
to work with but then also on the other
hand which character proved more
creatively fulfilling than you ever
could have imagined to explore with the
actor I don't know if I think about it
that way I mean it's a good question but
um it's such a great cast I was excited
to work with every last one of them I
was excited for pairings Sam Jackson and
Olivia Coleman Sam Jackson and Ben
mendelsohn Ben mendelsohn and Emilia
Clarke Sam Jackson and Kobe Smulders
it's all like those are the things
because when I come into it it's less
about
this person and it's more about the
scene and what the scene means and how
the scene is shaped and to have people
like that it just excited me to get a
little more specific with that I know
we're not allowed to talk spoilers but
in the earlier episodes is there any
particular scene that scene that people
can look out for that you know maybe
transformed in a way while you were
filming that you didn't expect where
what the actors brought to the scene you
know inspired you to Pivot or more
deeply or explore something that wasn't
originally in the plan yeah I don't know
I don't know that I can say it was more
wasn't in the original plan uh because
these things are so they evolve
constantly and there's not one turning
point that says oh now it's now it's
this um but I do think the scene with
Martin Freeman and Richard Dormer in the
very beginning really sets the tone the
for the theme and the look and the feel
and the octane and the I love that scene
the tension in that scene is palpable I
love it another thing that I've heard
you say that I'm curious about because I
feel like this is one of the most
challenging things to do with a
continuing franchise is to make a new
installment that appeals to longtime
fans but also functions as an on-ramp
for newcomers so can you maybe pinpoint
something that was a top priority for
you to do to appease the Marvel fandom
but that all but then also something you
were able to do for the series that you
know even if someone didn't know all the
history and the lore they still had that
on-ramp to jump in and make this
starting point one for them well
um I would first say that it's not
appeasing the audience it's delivering
for them right I mean I think it's
really
um and and I will say this is maybe not
the answer you're looking for but uh my
wife Robin is not such an MCU fan she's
seen with the kids we've seen but she's
not such a fan my son-in-law Ryan is the
greatest fan in the history of Marvel
Cinematic Universe and so we would apply
the robin Rule and the Ryan rule to
every decision we made which is can we
make a self-contained story that Robin
will understand and can we make a
self-contained story that Ryan will
accept into the and they both got to
meet Kevin feige last night so he met
the robin rule in the Ryan room I have
to know have Robin and Ryan reviewed the
first two episodes of secret Invasion
what do they think I'll I'll give you
their number and you can call them Ryan
would love to talk to you yeah I could
geek out about this franchise all day
long huge congratulations on the first
two episodes I can't wait to see more